24% من الشباب يستمعون الى الموسيقى
بمستويات غير امنه ما يعرض اكثر من مليار
شخص تقريبا لخطر حدوث مشاكل في السمع في
جميع انحاء العالم يحذر المؤلف دراسه من
جامعه كارولينا من ان فقدان السمع الناجم
عن الضوضاء غير قابل للاصلاح واننا بحاجه
الى تنفيذ استراتيجيات لمنع فقدان السمع
الدراسه شملت اكثر من 19 الف شخص تتراوح
اعمارهم بين
19.44 عاما اظهرت انهم تعرضوا لضوضاء
مفرطه من اجهزه الاستماع الشخصيه مثل
الهواتف الذكيه واجهزه الكمبيوتر المحموله
ويعتمد خطر فقدان السماء على مستوى الصوت
ومده ووتيره التعرض للضوضاء من ابرز
النصائح للحفاظ على السمع هو عدم التعرض
لمستوى صوت اكثر من 60% من مستوى الصوت
على الاجهزه ويجب حمايه الاذنين عن طريق
ارتداء سدادات الاذن في الاماكن الصاخبه
والابتعاد اصلا عن مصدر الصوت العالي
[موسيقى]